Vice President Mike Pence says it's up
to House Democrats to take action on the
overcrowding at migrant detention
centers pence made those comments Friday
after visiting a new detention center
near McAllen Texas inside cameras
spotted several hundred adult men being
held in caged like fences many of them
told reporters they were hungry and
wanted to brush their teeth
Friday night demonstrations and vigils
protesting the conditions in those
detention centers were held in cities
across the country outside the White
House and even on the doorstep of some
of those detention facilities Mireya
Villarreal has the story from the Texas
border station where the vice president
visited the vice president spent hours
touring Border Patrol facilities
including the Dona tent city near
McAllen Texas where he and his entourage
saw migrants sleeping on the floor CBS
News is blurring the faces of minor
children in custody but in the second
holding facility the Vice President was
faced with a much different scene nearly
400 men crammed behind caged fences with
not enough room for them all to lie down
the man telling reporters they had been
held there for nearly 40 days and that
they were hungry the room was hot and
the smell was strong the press was
pulled out within 90 seconds of the
visit with the vice president seven
Republican senators were with him but
not a single Democrat accepted the
invitation to come along each and every
one of the children each and every one
of the parents that I spoke to told me
they were being treated well Pence's
visit comes on the heels of a scathing
report from the Office of Inspector
General where one manager called the
situation at Border Patrol facilities in
June a ticking time bomb
at least five migrant children have died
in government custody since September in
Washington the House Oversight Committee
released a report saying at least 18
children under two years old were
separated from their parents for 20 days
- half a year at a hearing members
debated the conditions at migrant
detention centers that children being
separated from their parents in front
of an American flag when these women
tell me that they were put into a cell
and that their sink was not working and
we tested the sink ourselves and the
sink was not working and they were told
to drink out of a toilet bowl I believe
them Republican representative Debbie
Lesko says Democrats are exaggerating
they're not drinking out of toilets for
CBS this morning Saturday media vol
McKellan Texas